c'est un rituel provisoire qui dure
depuis mi juillet aux alliés c'est par
camion que l'eau arrive jusqu'aux
robinets des habitants un plan b est
vital qui tend à se répéter
dangereusement dans ce secteur
ça fait combien de camions l'a déjà fait
ce que tu madame le maire il vat on en a
une vingtaine
pour les alliés quarantaine pour la
commune voisine d'autres rédactrice 24
camions 25 mètres cubes de 120 euros
hors taxes le trajet 1 euros 29 le mètre
cube
voilà le chiffre est vite vite vu un à
ça nous plombe un budget carrément oui
pas le choix néanmoins branché sur vite
dupont les alliés aux tripes sa voisine
sont en bout de tuyau et donc au bout du
rouleau
pour elle le salut vient de pontarlier
de ses puits promu pour ailleurs
d'autres secours ont bien moins 10 mai
donc ces niveaux ces niveaux encore
baissé depuis ce jour devenir du moindre
pour le moment nous pouvons produire et
distribuer 9 1500 mètres cubes jour on
peut pas en distribuer 12 milles de ce
fait à moi donné il faut savoir
effectivement se restreindre par secteur
de façon à ce que la production
correspondent aux besoins
construit dans les années soixante dix
et dimensionné pour le bassin de
population de l'époque le circuit de
distribution de l'eau est largement
dépassé tout comme le volume de
production c'est l'enjeu principal du
schéma de cohérence territoriale du haut
doubs actuellement à l'étude mais
l'urgence est bel et bien là les
sécheresses les records de chaleur se
battent d'année en année le dérèglement
climatique
il ya un tas de facteurs qui me font
penser qu'on va avoir de plus en plus de
ceux ci au niveau de la communauté de
communes de montbenoit on a lancé une
étude de recherche en haut au niveau du
quart ce profond c'est cadeau
après ou la prendre comme on l'apprend
d'escale et de qualité voilà ça demande
du temps ça demande aussi beaucoup
d'argent pour avant qu'elle ne coule
dans les tuyaux en attendant certains
élus courageux fonds pris des décisions
radicales
la mort dans l'âme dans un secteur où la
terre vaut de l'or et où les frontaliers
ne demande qu'à ce
ni on a essuyé la colère des
propriétaires et on le comprend vraiment
parce que quand on est propriétaire d'un
terrain qu'on peut pas bâtir ni même le
vendre pour bâtir mais nous nous avons
fait un p lus ou à la restrictif avec un
commissaire enquêteur qui a abondé en
notre sens où nous avons pu faire passer
nos idées et dire voilà ici aux alliés
on bâtira pas tant que la ressource en
eau ne sera pas suffisante trouver de
l'eau l'assainir revoir les branchements
les débits un chantier monumental au cou
encore un chiffre est à ce jour et à la
durée hélas indéterminée et il coule de
moins en moins d'eau sous les ponts pour
se payer le luxe de prendre le temps